Cristiano Ronaldo is Muslim now
they should put that in the deal man a
million percent add that to the fine
print be like hey here's 500 million or
whatever the [ __ ] come to Saudi Arabia
and for two years you also have to be
Muslim wow
Andrew Tate did it again bro yeah he
came some [ __ ] you're kind of
smart so so this story what you're
saying is you want to break it down real
quick yeah basically a Saudi Team Al
Nasir I think is the name uh I think
they just confirmed to say they offered
him a multi-hundred million dollar deal
200 million a year for two years yeah
200 million a year for two years to play
in Saudi Arabia in the Saudi League
against only other Saudi teams crazy can
I ask you a question that's a crazy
amount of money
how what is negotiations like with a
Saudi team where it's like money's not
an even it's not even real to you yeah I
feel like I can say any number I want to
until you might behead me yeah literally
is that what it is is how you're trying
to fit like what number will make them
not feel disrespected and cut my head
off yeah 200 million why can't you say
201 Millions
who cares you could just go buy a
million dollar increments and they'd be
like all right fine you know what I mean
like why not
a year I bet they just said yes yeah
Messi if you go to the Saudi team 500
million a year what's weird about this
that like for example Beckham's deal he
came to LA Galaxy way back in this is
like 10 years ago now probably and I
think he got crazy money it was like
like record-breaking deal and I think he
got a piece of the MLS right yeah the
entire MLS I think it was a piece of the
league the entire league piece of the
league and then he got the option to buy
a team at any point in the future at a
capped price of for 25 minutes
like insane the Miami team or something
like that
insane deal like he got so much value I
don't think you can ascribe the same
value I mean granted MLS is different
but In fairness most of the MLS teams
are profitable whereas in Europe there's
a lot of teams that are not profitable
profitable so I'm like okay if even if
you buy an MLs franchise it might not be
that big and it might not be that
successful but it'll make money and you
have an actual asset for Cristiano he's
like okay I'm gonna go there get a bunch
of money but you can't really leverage
to like own a part of the league and I
don't know enough about the Saudi League
to think oh is there like a deal where
he can own the team and would that
actually be an asset that's worth having
feel like they're not giving up
ownership and nothing bro they even let
their wives drive cars they give you
ownership of it but you could ask for
any amount of money I feel like why
would you want ownership of a Saudi team
like well maybe there's money I don't
know wait what's that maybe there's
crazy money no you're right but I assume
everything is just propped up
you know but listen 200 million so 400
million or five or whatever it is
are you telling me that it's not worth
for him to come to the U.S and get a
piece of I don't even know if it's the
MLS but if it's [ __ ] the Miami team
what if he came this is what I would do
from him but maybe he's too competitive
wherever Messi's going which is I think
like FC Miami or something like that I
would go too
I joined FC Miami with Messi oh that'd
be crazy I want a piece of the team you
get a piece of the team this is going to
be the most popular team in the world
now maybe in soccer history in history
we're playing on the same team in
[ __ ] my I go back to our basil
for that that's the only condition that
I go home I would say give me a team I'm
taking ownership of a new team and it's
me and messy we're calling there's 50
50. that's it that'd be a great idea too
Miami is the perfect City for the both
of them yeah they're both Spanish
speakers they both uh are probably way
more familiar with like uh kind of well
definitely messy South American culture
I mean they both got famous through the
Spanish league absolutely like Real
Madrid this would be this to me is such
a no-brainer are you going to make less
money now sure I don't want to ever tell
somebody he doesn't need more money but
you have you probably have half a
billion dollars or something already
yeah you could take a 100 million dollar
deal now to then have it be worth
another half a billion in 10 years or
whatever you're getting that piece yeah
MLS is only going to explode especially
after what you guys do now you can still
technically do that after two more years
do get a half a billion dollars in Saudi
Arabia and then at 39 go play in the MLS
yeah it's two years ago missing out on
the brand deals you can get in the US
that Messi's gonna get I mean he ain't
got no 200 million dollar brand
that's a thing no no add them all
together no matter what you got from the
MLS could it come close to 200 to 450
million or whatever unless you get part
of the team or an option or something
and even then even then what do you
selling an MLS team for 80 million I'm
I'm just glowball it's it's skyrocketing
right now so get in early 250 you'll be
fine yeah the big franchises are
actually pretty good like LA Galaxy is
worth a lot I mean I'm just saying Miami
it seems to me is a perfect place for a
soccer team yeah
basketball nobody shows up yeah because
Miami is the Latin American version of
the United States of America yeah just
like I've said this before Hawaii is the
Asian version of the United States of
America the things that are popular in
Asia are going to succeed in Hawaii okay
simple as that things are popular in
Latin America are going to succeed in
Miami simple as that there's one comedy
club in Miami
stand-up isn't popular in South America
yet right of course there's just gonna
be one yeah right I guarantee these are
March 11 through 13th
but Messi can be in New York Spanish
speakers
and by the way values on the teams lafc
that just won 900 million oh Galaxy 865.
I am completely Atlanta 855. no no the
sport I think I want to check it but
this is an insane
NHL is like it's after you know get a
piece of the team and you both get a
piece even if you don't play
with each other with each other's just
crazy because who's gonna not go to that
game yeah we have to if you have the
opportunity you have to go yeah it does
crazy for the whole league can they play
well together I don't know like their
games enough I mean I mean probably I'm
not gonna say they can't especially in
MLS like they're both it's like so many
leagues above like the the entire league
but like still stylistically like
there's certain NBA players that like
you can't have them play with each other
I don't know I think it would be it
would be tricky because both the teams
like you're ideally trying to build the
team around the stars and if you have
two stars it's a trick you to build the
rest of the players did they used to
have a rule though like you could pay
one player X and then the second player
right the rule and then it's even across
and be like all right because every
single one yeah I think what he was
right can and a lot of like uh European
basketball teams do this you can have
like tops for American players yeah and
then the rest have to come from the rest
of the world or your country but yeah
every game they play anywhere they play
sold out and then you can take them
globally just like in the off season be
like hey we're gonna go do a match and
in Saudi Arabia and wherever we'll play
Liverpool in Saudi Arabia I mean this is
just I've gone to those like at the
Coliseum just it's the Harlem at that
point you get Cristiano messing on the
same team but he can still technically
do that and maybe they're too
competitive to play together but maybe
or maybe they finally just want to it's
fun they don't give a [ __ ] about playing
in America right this is just a bag that
you're gonna cash yeah and I mean this
just seems like such a [ __ ]
no-brainer but he can still do it he
could go two years make crazy money and
then come back and be like hey I have
all the leverage like you can't offer me
enough money you gotta offer me Equity
yeah but at least now there's this
feeling that they're yeah they're not in
their Prime but they're not too far
removed right they're still playing
World Cups they're still competitive
it's still scoring goals misses the
score in the World Cup right like at 39
you know last thing we want to do is see
washed Messi and Ronaldo yeah yeah
that's kind of what it feels like with
Beckham right we saw watch Beckham he
won a championship though yeah no I mean
he was competitive but like you're
getting everyone out of their quote
unquote Prime